et 41 milles dans la rue hier selon la
préfecture pour dire stop à l'extension
de la pma alors que le projet de loi de
bioéthique sera examiné au sénat à
partir de demain des voix continuent de
s'élever pour alerter sur la révolution
anthropologique majeur que contient ce
projet de loi mais sont-elles entendu
peut-on seulement encore en débattre le
député européen françois xavier bellamy
qui étaient dans la rue hier voici ce
qu'il confie à notre micro
on a le sentiment que le débat est
presque interdit aujourd'hui que le
simple fait de s'opposer à cette
révision des lois de bioéthique nouveau
généralement d'être considéré comme
ringard comme incapable de comprendre la
modernité c'est difficile pour les gens
d'assumer cette position alors j'ajoute
à cela des témoignages d'étudiants
recueillis hier qu'ils étaient dans le
parisien parmi eux il y avait par
exemple léonard 21 ans qui dit dès qu'on
est contre la paix hama pour tout en
nous caricature moi ça me gêne qu une
infertilité sociale soit réglée par la
loi
ai-je le droit de le penser et puis il y
avait yasmine qui a ajouté on m'a déjà
capté le cataloguer lesbophobes anti
féministe car je trouverai pas normal
que cette paix lama soit remboursée par
la sécurité sociale
stéphane marchand sur la forme est ce
que vous trouvez que le débat sur
l'extension de la pma et serein vous
savez la pma si on regarde quelques
chiffres pour qu'on sache bien de
comparer la pma est remboursé à 100% par
la sécurité sociale après accord
préalable de la caisse
43e anniversaire à compter de 6 ainsi
mination artificielle et quatre
fécondations in vitro
donc ça c'est la réalité aujourd'hui la
loi donc le problème là les
manifestations sont faut-il pour les
couples auto pour les femmes aux couples
hétérosexuels
faut-il étendre sa aux couples
homosexuels
faut-il étendre sa aux femmes seules
c'est ça la question que l'on pose
aujourd'hui est ce que le débat et sera
non est ce que le débat existe oui
monsieur bellamy à l'instant le prouvait
allègrement il est passé à la télévision
ou bien de voir ces 2
le débat glisse mais ce que vous
entendez quand même les arguments de ces
jeunes que je citais à l'instant qui
disent nous on est directement traitées
d'affreux réactionnaire catholique très
très à droite on n'a pas le droit de
dire aujourd'hui qu'on ait
éventuellement qu'on remettre en
question cette ce projet de loi je ne
connais pas assez jeune je sais qu'il
existe des extrémistes catholiques
je ne sais pas si ce sont les mêmes mais
le débat existe on vit dans un pays où
encore le débat est possible cela dit il
ya un parlement qui vote des doigts et
ensuite comment la loi est la loi c'est
la loi
judith waintraub vous êtes d'accord avec
ça le débat était plutôt apaisé alors je
me souviens d'un période où il était
beaucoup plus violent avec des violences
physiques notamment pendant le passage
de la loi taubira la 2013
on est là de ce point de vue là ça s'est
apaisée emmanuel macron s'en était
d'ailleurs ému rappelez vous pendant la
campagne présidentielle il avait dit
fallait il fallait pas humilier les
français les adversaires de
delap est vrai sans père et de la valley
forte hausse où elle avait dit je trouve
de ce point de vue là ça s'est apaisée
même s'il ya eu des contre-manif un peu
plus tard tout cas n'y a pas eu de
heurts il n'y a pas eu blessés mais vous
avez tout à l'environnement qui fait que
c'est effectivement difficile de tenir
ce discours là je pense notamment
la tentative de censure par anne hidalgo
vous savez des affiches d'alliance de la
campagne publicitaire de société une
grande maîtrise hier que dans les trois
affiches militait pour le respect de la
perte termites et le respect de la
maternité et le respect de la différence
en montrant un enfant handicapé
il n'avait pas sorti leurs affiches pour
le respect de la vie avec le
le vus les spermatozoïdes c'est une
association anti-avortement notamment
anti avortement la campagne de parrot
vie ne portait moi je dis ok fortement
la campagne ne portait pas là dessus est
vraiment les affiches n'avait absolument
rien de choquant d'ailleurs anne hidalgo
ne s'était guère ému quand la ratp avait
essayé de l'enlever l'armée ou la
mention chrétiens d'orient sur une
affiche qui annonçaient le passage d'un
concert d'un vrai leurs profits
s'appelait les frais du christ de rio
précisé thomas l'a donc il ya quand même
un deux poids deux mesures qui est assez
irritant de la part des institutions
maintenant que dans la société le
discours anti pema passe de moins en
moins on le voit aux chiffres vous avez
dit cité les chiffres de la préfecture
41 min voilà il se trouve le cabinet
occurrence que nous payons nous offrira
aux avec d'autres médias pour faire un
décompte plus fiable des manifestants
parlent de 26 me c'est beaucoup moins et
s'est notamment beaucoup moi que quand
le texte est passé et a été adoptée en
première lecture à l'assemblée nationale
68 74 milles dans le fait qu'il aura
donc dans le discours public les
antilles pays bas ont de moins en moins
d'écho on peut le constater et dans la
population
et puis les gens qui sont pas contentes
que les politiques ne ne porte pas aussi
cette voie là et notamment cordes télé
vote à droite qui s'en prennent à la
droite parce que la droite ne se gêne
pas pour ringardiser comme dirait
françois davy bellamy ce2 dans ses rangs
qui porte le fer sur le terrain sociétal
alors pour juste continuer le débat sur
sur la forme serait ce qu on a assez
parlé
anne fulda votre avis sur la question
est ce que votre avis ça a été au coeur
des débats en france parce que il faut
rappeler quand même que c'est un débat
qui est pas évident c'est compliqué ces
techniques et puis on essaie aussi sur
le plan moral
oui ça c'est un débat qui devrait
pourtant mobiliser parce que parce
qu'ils touchent au coeur de la
procréation au coeur de ce qu'est
l'homme ne sait ce que sont les
relations entre les hommes et les femmes
donc effectivement logiquement ça
devrait susciter plus de six années de
mobilisation en tout cas d'intérêt c'est
comme ça il se trouve que là la pma
existe depuis 94 et surtout pour
concerne les personnes et les couples
hétérosexuels attendent à fertilité là
c'est vrai qu'on change
on change de vision de panique puisqu'il
s'agit désormais de couples qui sont pas
obligatoirement intérêt social mais en
réalité je pense que s'il n'y a pas
cette mobilisation intellectuelle ou
politique c'est parce que finalement les
changements sont déjà intervenus dans la
société en réalité c'est pour ça je
pense qu'il ya qui a tellement peu de
personnes qui sont dans la rue c'est
parce que pour beaucoup
finalement la loi rattrape ce qui est
déjà acté depuis longtemps
oui c'est à dire que certains notamment
l'étranger voilà ça pour les couples
qu'ils peuvent
on a des personnalités aujourd'hui comme
marc olivier fogiel qui ont raconté qui
sait qu'en très précisément kiwis qui
font campagne et qui qui est et qui sont
à la tête d'une famille il explique
pourquoi comment tout en disant
qu'effectivement c'est parce qu'il a les
moyens qu'il a pu être aujourd'hui le
père de deux filles
c'est quelque chose qui est entré dans
la société je voyais l'autre jour un
feuilleton dans lequel le il y avait une
maîtresse qui s'adressait à une jeune
fille qui disait le mari ton papa qu'est
ce qu'ils en pensent
enfin c'est quelque chose qui rentrait
dans les moeurs donc je pense que c'est
ça qui explique cette mobilisation
cependant j'espère ajouter pas forcément
d'ailleurs comme acceptation dans le cas
dans l'est en tout cas dans les médias
enfin ou dans l'est dans les médias il
ya beaucoup de gens qui estiment que le
combat est perdu
voilà d'autres causes et la résignation
les oubliés cité tout à l'heure mais
c'est quand même important sylviane
agacinski qui est contre a quand même
été empêchés de ces philosophes
philosophe à bordeaux et on les en
empêcher
physiquement jacky isabello sur le plan
politique il semblerait que tous les
députés sont accueillants s'accordent un
petit peu implicitement à pas braquer
les projecteurs sur le texte en fait
c'est que des coups à prendre n'a aucun
intérêt à pour eux un entretien cette
contestation est ce que votre question
était de
est ce que le débat est possible
rappelez vous lors de la manif pour tous
le sujet a été assez violent et puis
force est de constater que les gilet
jaune sont passés par là et on a
l'impression que le débat est quasiment
apaisé sur ce sujet alors qu'il oppose
des franges de la population assez large
mécaniquement ce débat sur l'extension
de la paix m mécaniquement au dégoût
d'une manière ou d'une autre vous fait
se rencontrer si on sait religion et
c'est quand même le cas là depuis que le
monde est monde euh non non bien sûr
mais les traces de ce soir ça c'est moi
même ce sont quand même on parle
beaucoup d'un côté de science et de
l'autre côté il ya des basses eaux
extrêmement catholiques qui sont
mobilisés au sommet de corbas et que sur
le sur le débat dans l'opinion publique
on oppose ces deux sujets là et on sait
par nature que des cons mêlant science
et religion ce sont des sur deux sont
des sujets qui sont explosives après
depuis la guerre dès que vous
introduisez le sujet de la biologie
dans l'opinion publique pareil ce sont
des sujets qui sont extrêmement
volatiles et qui ne peuvent pas se mener
apaisé me direz vous est-ce qu'on peut
conduire un débat à peser et aujourd'hui
quel que soit le jeu sega loi leonetti
sur la famille
il n'a pas donné lieu à des débordements
soient judith la sphère vincent lambert
on va pousser tout commenté elle était
quand même pas très très apaisé et
rappelez-vous des prises de positions
extrêmement dur de part et d'autre de
cet avocat qui est à dans son code de
déontologie
l'obligation d'apaiser les débats et qui
se permet lui même de faire des
métaphores footballistiques sur un sujet
c'était assez peu mais bon voilà je un
kart difficile très médiatisé sur
lefigaro.fr on vous posez la question
selon vous peut-on encore débattre de
l'extension de la pma aux couples de
femmes et aux célibataires et vous êtes
une courte majorité 54% à dire que que
non et citoyen payeur qui commentent en
dix ans la pma est indispensable dans
les cas d'infertilité avérée dans un
couple hétérosexuel c'est tout un autre
internaute nous dit pour les femmes
seules et les couples homosexuels la pma
est une solution de confort aucun
remboursement ne devrait être admis et
enfin nicole nous dit aucun
remboursement de la sécu pour la pma
pour toutes
une dernière question sur ce sujet
judith ou et la droite
et justement c'est ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure elle est la première à
s'être interdit de faire de ce sujet un
sujet de débat en son sein d'abord parce
que les positions étaient diverses et en
plus parce qu'elle craignait
collectivement d'être ringardisé c'est
bon parler du rassemblement national
pour moi j'appelle pas l'extrême droite
marine le pen sera jamais été annoncée
centre géraldini ses chevaux de bataille
et il en va pas de même de marion
maréchal-le pen qui a souvent joué aux
trois qui ont retiré de la famille vole
pas eu je vous réponds jacky isabello
sur figaro.fr ai dit je suis contre la
pma sauf pour les couples stériles et je
ne suis pas